in fact he won 20 games
back in 2016.
gosling to right kepler looking up
and it is off the wall kepler will field
it gosling into second and he's in there
with a double and now iglesias with a
runner in scoring position
look i know we we featured eaton with
his defense
and we featured mayfield with his
offense last night iglesias did both he
had a couple doubles
and he was in the middle of that
brilliant relay throw to get the guy at
the plate
and he rips that one into left field
that's a base hit goslin
on his way home and he will score and
the angels are on the board
and it's iglesias again good swing for
glaciers who has been
crushing the baseball you go back to
this last 18 games
26 hits it's also two home runs five
doubles lines it in the left field and
lord is charging this one but a high
throw
again they'll be able to get a play at
the plate and allows iglesias to get in
his scoring position himself
gives kurt suzuki a chance with a base
hit to bring home the second run of the
inning
that ball is hit left field and deep
and gone kurt suzuki
two-run shot and the angels
hang three on jay happ here in the first
aloha
kurt suzuki
boy right in that wheelhouse kurt suzuki
well you talk about a great weight
transfer and that ball got out quickly
great swing by suzuki good start to this
game
one level the minor leagues are trying
to shorten that game of inches by
expanding the size of the bases
by six inches which doesn't sound like
much but it's three inches
at first base and three inches at second
base too
mayfield and his throw
does not get donaldson jocelyn
had to come off the bag to get the throw
and then gosselin and donaldson were
playing hopscotch over at first base
the ball was hit so hard i thought he
caught
him on the fly
you know angels are going to challenge
it appears which is odd they must be
pretty convinced
that gosselin got his foot on the bag
first inning challenge with a
three-nothing lead and this is a bit of
peculiar safe
so donaldson reaches first
the angels have lost their challenge
to the later innings but this guy was
having a huge year
in triple a 19 homers
drives it center field marshes there and
makes the running catch
and alex cobb escapes
twins leave them loaded angels three
nothing
[Music]
now mayfield
who in the bottom of the first had a
terrific diving catch
the throw brought goslin
off the bag mayfield
left field ante larnick back
gone
jack mayfield second night in a row
his third of the season and it's four
nothing
the captain kept the jack mayfield
back-to-back games with home runs
mayfield in another home run by a
right-handed batter that's a fastball
above the belt and he turns on it lifts
it out
that baseball had some hike to it so
launch angle
two donaldson another scorcher mayfield
again
and this time he throws him out
that's almost the exact same spot the
only difference
was the throw that is the hot corner and
it's a hot blast his way
and mayfield gets up
in better throwing position this time
right on the money to throw over to
goslin
alex cobb liking that play trying to
improve that number
batting average with runners in scoring
position
on the ground and that will help roller
to right
around third scoring is polanco and
laurie gets the twins on the board with
a two-out single
[Music]
swing in some tough splitties first
pitch split here
elevate it see the ball if it's high you
let it fly
but it's low you got to let that split
things go
a pretty decent move the first base
another stop at third and it's a double
play
donaldson has hit three smashes to
mayfield
and this time mayfield starts a double
play a run scores
but mayfield playing gold glove caliber
defense at third base
i'm making them forget about random for
a little bit
nice stop by it was a nice stop by jake
mayfield
to get up and still throw the ball to
second base
he knew he had enough time from his
knees i mean my goodness
joe man is out right now i wonder if
there's a
you know the fingernail or blister thing
going right now
and he's coming out it looks like so
this is going to take a while as cob
leaves
you look at first thing you look at his
pants to see if there's blood
anywhere because pitchers will wipe it
if it's a blister and it's bleeding
and you don't really see that gorgeous
against rooker base in right field
so around third he'll be waved in
and gordon delivers an rbi single and
it's four to three
breaking ball and the right field for
rbi base hit
that's no scoring 4-3
see what the twins have in mind here
with gordon's speed at first base
it definitely could have been you're
selling a different look for him off the
glove
bare hand throw got him
have a night is that brooks robinson the
third jack mayfield
in the shift pulled over watson got a
glove on it and kepler is out
i still love a great defensive play even
better than a power strikeout or a home
run that's
he's got a redirect to come in with the
bare hand
and throw out a good base runner down
the line at max kepler
and now the go-ahead run is on the tiger
run at second
and the batter is jeffers for three
angels
looking for another one here with one
out in the eighth line drive base hit to
left field
so now the third they're gonna wave him
around lagarus with the throw offline
and the twins have tied it up and now
the throw
into left field here comes gordon and he
will score
good piece of hidden from jeffers didn't
get fooled by the
breaking balls they line that ball in
the left field and you know
tony diaz regardless has a very strong
arm
wasn't able to make a good throw
nick was aggressive coming around second
base went to third
was able to score on the
wild throw from suzuki one run batted in
for jeffers but two runs score and the
twins have their first lead
popped up polanco squeezes it
rogers gets the save and the twins even
the series
had a game of peace with a nice come
from behind win
some very good pitching half was able to
settle down after those rough first two
innings and gave his chance his team a
chance to win a ball game